Hello, this is Frank Defradis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of March twenty-sixth, two thousand.
I'm in the studio and Michelle Roy is with us again this week.
Hello, Michelle, how are you?
I'm good, Frank.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
Um we're going to bring you the second show in a series of five shows that we recorded when we were out in Long Island City, New York at the Center for the Holographic Arts.
And today's guest is Dan Schweitzer.
And Michelle, you did the interview with Dan and I just had a chance to edit it and listen to it.
It's a great interview.
Oh thanks.
I was just sitting here trying to remember what we talked about.
I did I remember having a good time with the interview.
Thanks for tuning in.
I guess we'll just move right on to the show because I wait, you can't think of anything else to say.
I can't think of anything else to say.
Why don't you say something?
I think the show pretty much speaks for itself.
It was a good show.
We had fun.
Lots of laughing, which is always good, I think.
Mm-hmm in the show.
Yeah.
And uh that's it.
That is it.
All right, here's the show.
Don't forget to tune in each and every week, and we'll have the third show in this series next week.
So thanks for tuning in to HoloTalk.
See you next week.
I thought you were doing Mary.
No, we're doing Dan.
Yeah.
Well, the reason why we're doing Dan is we did Adam Maria Nicholson last week, who is one of the directors and founders.
Oh, sure.
Okay, that makes sense.
Even though time-wise uh Mary was the second person we interviewed, I figured show wise it might be good to do Dan because he's the co-director, co-director.
Yeah, well that makes sense.
You just didn't let me I wasn't in on the thought process there.
Oh, I see.
That that was, you know, once you explain it to me now it makes sense and I'm I'm with you on that one.
Alrighty.
But you know.
So I'll go over now and now you can turn this up.
Okay.
We're back at the show with Dan Schweitzer and Michelle Roy.
And if you want to hear the interview that we did previously with Dan, just go right onto the archive page.
And I think we have a show there that lasts about forty or forty-five minutes with Dan.
So I'm not going to repeat some of the questions that I asked him during that show.
So what I'm going to do is turn the microphone back over to Michelle Roy, who wants to ask Dan a few questions about how to get involved with holography and well, she'll be better to ask those questions than I can to be able to tell you.
So here she is.
Especially the way you're talking right now.
I think Frank's been hitting the been been hitting the wine over a at any rate to return to the uh purpose of being here.
Dan, what I wanted to talk to you first of all about was sort of your own interest and work in holography in terms of you know what got you interested in doing this as a career, what you know made you decide, you know, this as opposed to being a professor, I don't know, anything.
Yeah, auto mechanics, exactly.
What got you into this?
I uh it's a serendipitous kind of experience.
Um I think I mentioned in a prior interview with uh with Frank that uh that my my involvement was really by almost by accident, but once I I got my first class in holography, it was it w the the the concept behind the recording process was so extraordinary.
And it it just appealed to my philosophical side as much as anything else.
And uh and the ability to to do something that's never been done before.
I mean there is nothing more exciting than knowing that when you do something, no one has been there before.
You feel like a pioneer.
And uh and and when you when you begin uh for me, science was always a very difficult field.
And for the first time as an adult, I was able to apply scientific principles to something that created a visual image was extraordinary.
So as I got more and more excited about the science, at the same time more and more excited about the image, and the two sort of evolved at the same time and I found that I could express what I was learning in in an artistic statement that had emotion behind it, that had the the desire to to communicate the excitement that I was having over discovering about science and light because so much of our what we know in our minds comes through our eyes to break that down and to um to begin to understand how light behaves and then to be able to turn it around and express it in some kind of a philosophical and or emotional statement was it was a was r remarkable combination of elements that that managed to pry me away from my theatrical instincts.
So you actually began in another aspect of the arts, I guess, in drama.
We talked earlier with Mary who's a painter, as well as working in holography.
Do you work in other media uh as well or it's sticked strictly to holography?
I a lot of my work actually I I had always had a side career of doing small sculpture work.
Um and it just interfaced very well.
Right with philography where I was able to use some of the work that I had originally done prior to even knowing about holography and incorporate that.
There was also a link in there because I went from basically from doing theater to um video to film where I where I performed and uh uh but then back to video again with my partner Sam Moray uh with the New York holographic labs um we we did uh a number of projects involved with video where we we used a lot of our small sculptures to create abstract scenarios if you will and uh turned out that the models lent themselves very well to the holographic frame and uh and so it there was a logical step from one thing to another and uh then the then that became another thing where the original sculptures I made holograms of and then eventually the whole the sculptures became exterior to the hologram and interrelate with the projected light images from the hologram so that became sort of a little theater for me.
So now I was in control of everything so you're you're a control freak is that exactly I have none whatsoever freak.
I'm an out of control freak exactly thank you I think I'll write that down put that on my resume out of control freak which has a couple of meanings depending on where you put the emphasis in that's right.
Now we were talking earlier before we began the recording about some courses at the School for the Visual Arts.
Can you tell us a little bit about those courses and what kinds of things you you know cover in those courses, what experiences students have during the course?
It's really a practical course um uh i i it it is uh as it stands right now at the school is an elective um it's not within the art department but um it takes a very curious person to make a selection like that from the school.
And it it really it's uh it's a matter of just bringing them from very basic steps, single beam reflections, transmissions, um, in our first semester up through image plane reflection type holograms, and then the advanced class deals in white light ref white light transmission holography, and that's where we are right now with the class.
And so we're doing one step rainbows, and um it's so fortunate that we have this center here because we now have the pulse laser available to us.
So a lot of the tedious problems that we often have with making uh master holograms can be uh alleviated by at least having a day out here where we can make masters out here.
We combine those masters with uh masters that we do on the uh on the isolation table at at uh New York holographic labs, and we can come up with some pretty good results.
But it's a matter of experimenting and letting them get curious and challenging them to uh use their creative instincts to try and capitalize on the medium.
It's always a difficulty because it's new.
They don't really know what is coming next until we do the shot.
But once they see our first test results, then they can begin to to design the works.
And generally out of a class we do come up with some pretty good results, you know.
Do you find that um the students struggle more with the I shouldn't put it that way, that sounds so negative, but w what's more of a challenge?
The uh creative aspect of it or the technical aspect?
When you look at painting or something like that, you may have uh you may feel you have more control if you will, but you know, the technical aspect is is can be seemed difficult, I think, to people because they're not as familiar with it, maybe.
Well, or did it is it not a challenge?
It's a twofold uh it's it's very clearly a twofold challenge as it as it is with any artist coming into the medium.
You you you have a vision, you have an idea of what you think you'd like to do, but until you really begin to work with the medium, you you you're not really on firm ground yet.
So when you see what's possible and what isn't, your vision will change.
You you you ultimately you you end up having to match your idea to what is possible in technology.
And uh clearly holography is not like the computer world, it's not very instant.
You you really do have to stay with it and master it.
It's like a it's a bit of a stubborn beast sometimes.
I I I I'm thinking of marketing uh spurs for holograms.
Right the wild hologram isn't it?
Take these spurs with you.
But it but i eventually you do come to terms with it, and sometimes some real genuine magic can happen.
Do you find that certain types of students seem to be attracted to the class as opposed to, you know, since it is an elective.
I I know you mentioned earlier that um you have to be a a particularly curious kind of person, probably.
But are there other things that you've noticed in in the students?
Well, um I mo as uh uh most of the students are photography majors, a lot of them are photography majors.
So they have they have imagery in mind and they have content in mind.
Um this is the age where people are pursuing things that they know are going to pay off economically.
And so i it we're not in demand quite yet because what we do um is not out there quite so much.
So particularly photography.
Right.
Well what I stress, what I stress with the with the students is that if you never make another hologram in your life after you finish with our classes, it doesn't matter.
We're not we're not teaching you to be a holographer.
What we're trying to do is teach you a little bit about the process, the concept, the recording process, which is so remarkable.
The holographic paradigm is very much a part of my rap in terms of teaching.
Because I believe that the way light behaves is a metaphor for the way life behaves in a lot of ways.
And and I think that you can learn lessons from from holography that you might not learn using other media that might have nothing to do necessarily with your career, but something to do with a way of thinking or a way of defining your own universe.
And uh and so I don't feel necessarily rejected if my students don't go on to become famous holographers, although many have and I'm proud of that.
No not that I m made them good, I just introduced them as as Frank can well testify to.
You can start people but you don't you don't you don't do it for them.
You have to bring the stuff with you.
Um but I think that there's a lot to be gained from philography even if you don't really go into it as a career.
Clearly it would be great to be able to go into it as a career, but even if not, I think there's so much to be learned as a part of the process, if nothing else, discipline.
So do you think you need to come into it with discipline or are you learn that discipline and patience?
It teaches you discipline.
For those people who grow up with a computer where it all happens right away and actually it doesn't really do that, does it?
No, you struggle with everything we work with.
If you want to be good at something, you have to really apply yourself and you have to be dedicated, whether it's uh sim seemingly simple technology like computers or or holography, which uh seemingly is high tech and as it turns out turns out to be even more like sound light plumbing.
We're all plumbers.
I've been plummeting ever since no that's different.
I was gonna say plumbing and plummeting.
Very different concepts.
Um well I really appreciate you talking with us Dan I don't know Frank do you have any other questions?
I just wanted to say that that was a great interview.
And I want the HoloTalk listeners to write in and let me know.
Do you want me to stay with the show or do you want Michelle want to take over?
No I don't have any more questions.
I rest my case thanks Dan and bye bye